you i assume you got they read you the
rules and all that stuff oh you met them
oh yeah there was a whole
list of things did you pay attention to
those rules you did not billy eilish
says she totally broke protocol when she
met the royal family at the world's
premiere of the new james bond film no
time to die
dude
what like i don't even know
earlier this month the grammy winner and
her brother
frequent collaborator phineas made their
way across the pond for the big event in
london and were snapped chatting it up
with the royal family so on wednesday
when the 19 year old singer stopped by
jimmy kimmel live the talk show host
just had to ask about meeting kate
middleton prince william prince charles
and his wife camilla
you i assume you got they read you the
rules and all that stuff oh you met them
oh yeah there was a whole
list of things did you pay attention to
those rules you did not billy says she
intended to follow the guidelines but
just got swept up in the moment i tried
to i was planning on it and they were
just so normal like they were just they
didn't make me feel like oh i'm scared i
can't talk to them and they were they
were like very question like they just
complimentary and they had all these
questions for me and they
they were just very friendly and like
funny and sweet i don't know i can't
complain and it was amazing of course
billy sings the movie's theme song also
called no time to die which she co-wrote
with phineas can't wait for the bond
song one word to describe
bond i don't know okay it's gonna be fun
[Music]
and billy she wasn't the only star at
the premiere to chat it up with the
royals i just blessed and so grateful
rami malek told et all about his
experience meeting the famous family it
was extraordinary to have you know the
royal family join you
you just can't you you can't ever expect
these moments i was sitting right behind
them during the entire film so i got to
gauge their reaction from their body
language you're thinking you're you got
two thumbs up uh uh that was the feeling
that was a response i'm definitely not
gonna put words in their mouths but
yeah they see they seem pretty taken
aback by the film what do you say to the
duke and duchess for me i just try to
treat them like i would anybody else
yeah i'm sure like a dose of
uh normality is probably something uh
that's quite refreshing to them but back
to billy the royals are hardly the only
celebs billy has rubbed elbows with in
recent months last month the bad guy
singer co-chaired the met gala which was
attended by some of hollywood's biggest
stars it's
like the most insane honor you would not
believe i feel like that i'm in a dream
i feel like i'm like
tripping
and when it spoke with billy on the
famous steps at the met she gushed over
the incredible opportunity you said that
you were feeling a lot of nerves that
yeah like good ones though like nothing
literally not one bad i just am like
this is the most exciting thing i've
ever done